ultimately if you're gonna have lasting
change in anything you're really talking
about just raising your standards
lasting change is different than a goal
you don't always get your goals but you
always get your standards you must be
above a list of [ __ ] so when you decide
something as a must for you an absolute
must when you cut off any possible you
say I'm gonna find the way I'm gonna
make the way human beings when they
resolve things and they have make a real
resolution inside themselves which is
they raise the standard they make it a
must they find the way I'd like to ask
you to take a look at any place you've
got a limitation ask yourself when did I
decide to accept that limitation and you
may not even see it as a limitation you
might see they're just that's who I am
but so often in our lives we've adapted
to be a certain way so that we don't
fail or so that people will like us or
respect us but it's not necessarily who
we are we live who we believe we are
you've got to separate the vehicle from
the outcome what is it that's gonna
truly fulfill you what is it that's
gonna give you that extraordinary life
what's gonna make things magnificent on
your terms not somebody else's terms not
your father your mother your background
what is that really separate the
vehicles there's many ways to get to
that vehicle sometimes you got to
reevaluate what's gonna really make you
fulfill what is your gift
are you an artist are you the talent
that can produce something no one else
produced are you an extraordinary
entrepreneur that has can take that
gigantic gut load of risk and can create
the vision and attract the talent that
you need and the managers and leaders
you may have all three abilities but
which one really fulfills you the most
is going to be the critical question
because we tend to want to do them all
so you say I can do all these yes you
can but what will it do to your quality
of life see again the secrets going to
be this what is an extraordinary life on
your terms today you just watched two
amazing clips from Tony Robbins take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you